Demandez... vous l'avez !
Patientez... vous avez  !
Voici comme le titre l'indique,
la 1ère partie de ma bibliothèque.
1ère partie parce que, déjà, je n'ai pas encore
ramené tous mes livres, ici, dans ce bureau ;
Et 1ère partie parce que, en une seule
vidéo, ça ne sera pas possible.
Et pour vous parler de mes livres aujourd'hui,
il me faut un outil indispensable ...
Mes lunettes !
[ Musique du générique]
On va se poser tranquillement ici, puis je vais prendre les livres un peu dans l'ordre où ils me viennent.
Et peut-être aussi par ordre historique.
Par exemple ça, c'est un des 1ers livres
que j'ai eu et qui m'a ouvert à plein plein de choses.
Ca s'appelle "Cours Magica" de Robert Veno.
La version de ce copyright là
c'est de 1954.
Et à l'intérieur, de ce bouquin,  j'ai pu y trouver tout ce qui était manipulation de pièces, de cartes...
Et vraiment écrit à l'ancienne...
Avec de magnifiques planches dessinées à la main qui expliquaient les mouvements, comment les faire ...
Et c'était découpé en chapitres,
en 12 leçons.
Dont ma première rencontre avec
le mot mentalisme.
Dans ce chapitre là appelé :
"Magnétisme spiritisme divination et
transmission de pensées"
Et là dedans on abordait un sujet
qui était le "pas de truc".
Il n'y a pas de truc.
Ce qui me fait immédiatement penser
à un autre livre de « Doc »
"Les principes brillants du mentalisme"
qui contenait justement un chapitre
qui s'appelle : "Y'a pas de truc !"
Et la version française de
ce bouquin date de 1981.
Ces deux livres ont été écrits
et imprimés avant que je naisse.
Oui, je suis né après 1981.
Ça va oui ?!
Alors ces allusions sur mon âge...
Quel âge j'ai d'abord ?
Je ne sais même pas quel âge j'ai...
Et maintenant plutôt que
de vous donner une chronologie,
je vous propose de prendre 3 livres, au hasard,
dans la bibliothèque et... je vous en parle.
1er livre :
[Rires]
Je ne suis pas sûr
que vous allez kiffer !
C'est "le guide marabout des échecs".
Les plus belles tactiques.
C'est un très bon livre
soit dit en passant.
Je vous raconte
l'histoire rapidement ?
Je savais jouer,
en terme de règles,
Mais j'avais une très mauvaise stratégie,
en fait je n'en avais quasiment pas.
Et à l'âge de 8 ans je suis parti
en vacances avec ma marraine,
j'ai rencontré un mec là-bas
qui jouait aux échecs
qui avait 20/25ans
et on joue aux échecs ensemble,
et en partant il m'a offert ce bouquin là
pour que je puisse comprendre
les principes stratégiques et tactiques.
Pas sûr que ce soit un livre comme ça
que vous attendiez !
On y retourne, je pioche...
"Cold reading, rapide et efficace"
de  Webster.
Vous n'allez pas trop kiffer
si vous cherchez du cold reading
tel que vous l'entendez
à la Sherlock Holmes.
C'est pas un livre de cold reading du tout,
c'est un livre sur la chiromancie.
Donc le palm reading : la lecture
des lignes de la main.
Et beh je ne l'ai pas refermé.
Je l'ai lu,
et ça m'a profondément intéressé, parce que
tout m'intéresse de manière générale.
Je ne crois pas dans les lignes de la main,
je ne crois pas nécessairement à tout ça,
c'est pas grave, ça n'empêche pas
qu'il y ait une vraie culture derrière tout ça.
Et ça n'empêche pas de
s'intéresser à cette culture-là.
Quand je vous dis que je l'ai lu et que je m'y suis interessé...(oui voilà c'est ça...)
C'est que vous pouvez voir que...
oui, effectivement, en plus je surligne beaucoup
tous les passages qui m'intéressent.
Je re-note parce que des fois
je corrige aussi des mots...
C'est rigolo de le faire comme ça en piochant, parce que moi je tombe sur des éléments de vie
Ce livre-là je ne pense pas que j'aurais
pris le temps de vous en parler réellement
si je n'étais pas tombé dessus au hasard.
Allez...prochain bouquin
Ah j'en avais parlé je crois
un petit peu dans une vidéo
Dans une ancienne vidéo du mental vlog.
Tu me diras, on n'était pas nombreux
à cette époque sur la chaine.
Je ne sais même pas si on était
10 000 quand j'en avais parlé.
Il est difficile à trouver aujourd'hui, c'est un des meilleurs livres que j'ai lu sur le mentalisme
"Ex nihilo" d' Angelo Stagnaro.
Le sous titre c'était :
"Le guide du cold reading moderne"
[Lecture] Une analyse du langage du corps,
de l'intuition,  de l'équivoque
de l'interprétation des mouvements musculaires,
du charisme de l'anthropologie culturelle,
des statistiques, des forces psychologiques,
des tours de mentalisme,
de l'observation et de la causalité,
et du bon sens.
Et ça fait partie d'une trilogie qui s'appelait :
"Ouvrages psychologiques"
Bah là plus besoin de trop vous le détailler
par rapport à tout ce que j'ai dit,
au début, sur la 1ère page, vous avez
à peu près le contenu du livre.
Alors, comme tout ce genre de livre,
il y a du bon et du moins bon.
En fait, l'idée, pour reprendre le mot curieux,
c'est d'être un petit peu curieux de tout ça.
Donc il ne faut jamais se fermer complètement,
ça ne coûte rien de lire
et de garder du recul
par rapport à ce qu'on lit.
Et après vous éliminez
ce qui ne tient pas la route pour vous.
On est à combien de livres là ?
Quatre ? C'est tout !?
Faut que j'en fasse un petit peu plus
quand même...
Next ! Je vais aller un peu plus
dans le fond, tiens, ce coup-ci.
Ah ! J'aime bien celui-là.
"Influence et Manipulation"
de Cialdini.
C'est un professeur en
psychologie sociale
Et il y a toutes ces années de travaux et de recherches qui sont à l'intérieur de ce livre.
Il est assez bien écrit
Je veux dire, il n'est pas lourd à lire.
Alors ne vous attendez pas à avoir des images, hein...
On est sur de la théorie pure et dure.
Extrêmement intéressant,
je vous mets un lien dans la description.
Je pense qu'on le trouve encore facilement,
plus facilement encore que "Ex Nihilo"
Il parle même de références
historiques sur les claques.
Les claques : ce sont ceux qui,
au théâtre, sont payés,
étaient payés du moins,
ça n'existe plus vraiment aujourd'hui...
pour applaudir fort,
pour crier fort...
Il y avait... euh...
le bisseur par exemple.
C'est quelqu'un qui, au théâtre,
au XXème siècle, criait :
" Bis ! Bis ! Bis ! "
pour que tout le monde, en fait,
ait envie de voir un dernier numéro.
Et il parle de toute l'influence que ça avait sur le groupe, enfin... c'est bourré de choses comme ça à l'intérieur.
Bon j'en prends un pas au hasard ce coup-ci.
"L'art de la guerre"
de Sun Tzu.
C'est une de mes bibles, c'est à dire que
j'ai, comme ça, un top de livres
auxquels je suis capable de me référer
très régulièrement.
Et qui m'apportent beaucoup parce qu'ils ont
des lectures intéressantes
si tu les transposes
sur d'autres univers.
Allez, on part sur un petit lien
dans la description...
Allez je vous en fait un tout dernier.
Je ne sais plus du tout à combien on est...
C'est lequel? Ah !
"Les énigmes de Sherlock Holmes"
J'ai plein de bouquins d'énigmes,
il y en a d'autres d'ailleurs à côté,
il y a "Les énigmes de Dante"
Je trouve qu'il n'y a rien de mieux
qu'un livre d'énigmes
pour se stimuler à voir
les choses différemment.
Si vous aimez bien l'univers de Sherlock Holmes,
celui-ci vous allez kiffer!
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez?
On part sur un petit
lien dans la description ?
Bah, bien sûr !
En plus celui-ci il a de particulier
d'avoir un fil rouge.
Enfin... celui-ci...
Dante aussi il y a un fil rouge
Je crois qu'en fait c'est de plus en plus courant
les livres d'énigmes avec un fil rouge.
Et bien voilà pour cette première partie
de bibliothèque, ça me parait pas mal!
De toute manière comme vous me réclamez
cette vidéo-là depuis longtemps,
je me suis dit aussi :
"Faisons un test"
On fait déjà cette première partie,
relativement rapide,
je ne sais pas combien de temps
ça va faire au final.
Et s'il y a beaucoup de questions
dans les commentaires
par rapport à tous ces bouquins,
où si vous demandez si j'ai lu
tel ou tel ou tel livre
vous pouvez aussi me le mettre.
Une fois n'est pas coutume,
un tout petit rajout :
Vous vous souvenez de Carine Erseng
et Victor Barange avec qui j'avais fait la F.A.Q. ?
L ' ALFA-Q !
Ils font chacun de leur côté
de la french pop.
Et, pour la 1ère fois, ils vont être en concert,
ensemble, la semaine prochaine.
Le 23 mars à Paris,
sur une péniche-théâtre,
là où j'avais joué, moi,
l'année dernière.
Et je voulais vous le dire parce que,
d'une : pour ce qu'ils avaient fait pour l'ALFA-Q,
c'était énorme !
Et de deux : parce que ce sont
des artistes de ouf!
Si vous avez l'occasion,
allez les voir!
J'ai eu Carine Erseng à l'instant au téléphone,
et le petit bonus c'est que
si, à l'accueil,
à la billetterie,
vous dites que vous venez
de la part de la Team Mentalo,
ou que vous faites partie
de la Team Mentalo :
Et bien la 2ème place vous sera offerte!
Donc si vous êtes plusieurs à vouloir y aller, organisez-vous dans les commentaires.
Voilà c'était juste là-dessus.
Je vous jure c'est énorme,
moi je ne rate aucun de leurs concerts.
Passez un très bon weekend.
Je vous donne rendez-vous lundi,
pour une vidéo
par...ti...ci...pa...tive
Ou...iii
Save the date !
Lundi 17h30 !
Ciao !
[Musique du générique de fin]